brown's hands or tatum and attack get  into the paint be aggressive don't  settle  on this possession brown drives in  thai game 107-107  eight seconds to go  down to three seconds two seconds touch  it for the win  oh yeah luca duncan  the decker  incredible bird two  big time shots on consecutive  possessions  and down the stretch luca gets to his  spot step back  deep three two people on him  and he's showing why he is in a all-star  luca donches de don coming up big  for his ball club  [Applause]  31 for doncic  and the biggest shot of the night  belongs  to luca  there is point one on the clock  they will check to see if they can tack  on a couple of tenths of a second  based on when that ball went through the  hoop  boston using the timeout  [Applause]  the man